hi there um it's my pleasure
to introduce the arts science and
culture session
of today's conference um sometimes
you get some really cool stuff when you
mix the arts and sciences
art and science can be a bit like lovers
with very different backgrounds
but when they do get it together the
offspring come out
vibrant and supercharged we believe
amazing projects like these next three
can open up
some of the research being done to a
much broader audience
and with that in mind please let me
introduce you to the three talks
we have arachnophilia um with
uh marcus buhler thomas saraceno and
evan zipperin i hope i got the names
right
the second talk is do bees like van
gogh's
sunflowers from lars chitka from queen
mary
university of london and finally from
claire brooks
of google arts and culture and the
artist christina tarquini
art emotion and ecology the heartbeat of
the earth
so please uh marcus would you take us
away
great thank you so much peter and great
to meet you all an amazing conference
i've been enjoying the talks this
morning
so our contribution will be discussing a
work on on spider webs and
we have three speakers but this is part
of a very large team i would say
international team of
uh many folks my graduate student
isabelle sue who's traveling today and
could enjoy join unfortunately
ian hadwick christine southworth tomas
ivan you'll meet later again
and many others actually who have worked
on this in the studio and at mit over
the years and the
project um is focused on spiderwebs and
looking to spiderwebs for inspiration to
understand nature to design materials to
make music perform
music under lauren from spiders and
tomas will show an amazing video
of spider divination and asking
questions to spiders that is still
being used today in in indigenous
cultures which
can teach us a lot about communications
across species and between species so
um i will try to introduce the the scope
of what a spider web is a little bit in
the next minute or so and then i will
hand it
over to um tomas and um
um and evan to share additional thoughts
and then we'll have a conversation
amongst us while the slides
will play so um please um share the
slides now
we're going to be looking at a spider
web in particular
the interesting spiderwebs we've been
studying are cobwebs essentially three
dimensional webs that look a little bit
different
than the typical orbit that you might
have seen
if you were asked to be draw a web you
would usually draw an augway but of
course most spider webs are
three-dimensional
and quite complex you can see this in
this beautiful photo installation that
must come
maybe you could share the screen because
it didn't went through sorry to
interrupt
oh i'm so sorry i i am sorry
thank you to us i i was i was getting
messages
and i was not sure what's going on i am
so sorry here we go does this work
yeah fantastic okay great well we're
essentially i i want to show the title
page this is again just the
if you want to see the name so this is
all of us um and others that have worked
on this
and um again we're very excited to be
part of this today so apologies for the
screen
sharing issue but i think we'll have
soon fatigue a little bit so
um things happen but um yeah so we we're
looking at spider webs like this
beautiful picture here
of the web that tomas created a couple
years ago a three-dimensional web which
as i mentioned is quite different from a
2d web orb that we usually see
but those are the kinds of webs we've
been studying um and this has been a
collaboration between the studio
in berlin atomas ivan and others at mit
uh in my lab and we
have had a lot of fun i would say over
the years and each of us in the
conversation we'll have the next
um you know 10 minutes or so we'll share
our own perspectives and viewpoints and
ideas and we'll hopefully have some
interesting synergies between the
discussion but
um first i want to just spend a few
minutes to introduce the project and
what these spider webs are you can see
they have some really interesting
structures
um you know spiderwebs are inspiration
for us not only at the visible scale but
also the invisible scale
um this is so how the spiderweb looks
like in the inside spiderwebs are made
from proteins
which go all the way down to the
nanoscale things we cannot see
but things that are there um atoms
molecules and which provide
enormous insights for us for the
materials community
um as well as for the arts community and
learning how the connections actually
can work
between sound vibrations which is what
the spider lives in a vibrational
universe
um all the way to the using using a web
for divination or spider actions
divination as well as using it as an
instrument which evan will will talk
about in a moment
um and the the connections between these
different aspects of how nature works
is something that this project has has
worked on i want to
maybe show a little bit of the history
of this so we began actually thomas and
i met
um at mit a few years ago when he became
a resident artist at cast at mit
uh we had a panel together which in fact
actually also allowed us to interest my
graduate student isabelle sue who worked
with me for the past five or six years
on this project
she was in the audience and she loved it
so much this intersection between
science and art that she he joined the
team
um then thomas came to mit and brought a
spider
which we're very grateful for as you
could see in the author list one of the
co-authors of this talk is the spider
who
makes the webs and inspires us things to
study and to learn from
and become closer to nature and learn
this language of how nature creates
things and how nature creates sounds and
communication students have worked in
on developing a method to scan these
webs based on
work that tomas had done originally in
berlin and germany
we have digitized these websites and
created at mit a way to create graph
models of webs which
are digitized versions of the web this
is sort of how it looks like when you
fly through the web using lasers you can
then build these models
and once you have a model of these webs
you have these beautiful
three-dimensional presentations of the
original web that live in a computer
and you can do we can do many things
with this um including building
visualizations analyzing the structure
the mechanics of the web
failure of the web as well as looking at
different aspects different sections of
the web to understand
how structures and functions relate and
how the ecology could be mimicked
perhaps in 3d printed wraps as shown
here so these are mimics that we've made
from these webs and i will hand it over
to um
thomas and then ivan i think you'll come
in as well later
we've done a lot of different things
with these webs including um creating a
musical instrument that makes sounds
based on treating the web as a harp
uh tomas has become has led the effort
around the world in creating
a really new way of connecting webs and
spiders and humans and maybe tomas
i'll hand it over to you here to talk a
little bit about this this uh this
project
yes thank you could you could you hear
me is working
yes yes thank you no thank you marcos
for this beautiful
introduction and and yeah just only say
a few words that
yeah the the group arachnophilia is
really very diverse
and this means sometimes we really kind
of go through to
try to incorporate as many form of
knowledge we could have
if we could move a little bit to the
slide where is the diviner bolo
in the video that yes and we will see
uh now this small video as the start of
the introduction
if we can put out the sound it is
possible
[Music]
foreign
um
translation by david
okay uh so it has chosen the stone
which means it disagrees with marcus's
interpretation
it doesn't affirm his statement his
principle
but it is pointing ahead so there
is things
ahead of him which i think in this
context means
he can develop his principle to make it
less
wrong
the other way around for confirmation
okay
thank you for sharing this i mean this
balloon from the community of somnia in
cameroon and then
he's a designer and who asked a question
to spiders he transmits his
question through moving a stone through
this pen that transmit this vibration to
the spider
and the whole village when they have a
kind of very important questions are
asked to inspire them despite they
participate in the organization of the
village with their knowledge and their
wisdom
see before i travel there i asked marcus
bieler that we share
together the community which question
mark will do
and the question that marcus said is
there is a principle of universal
diversity
as i mean the spider answer his he
disagree
but he have to reformulate the questions
to try to make it less wrong which i
thought is very beautiful gives me just
a little bit to give you the scope also
emma anderson have asked the spider if
the current president of america in this
time
was donald trump will be re-elected and
destroy the spider answer
that will not be re-elected because i
mean what we are looking is a little bit
like between science and different form
of knowledge how we can broaden
this idea that there are many cultures
and many forms of wisdom that already
are very much connected
to to the knowledge and the wisdom of
others
and a little bit to give it a little bit
of a context uh you know there is a
philosopher marisol de la cadena
do not talk about the anthropocene not
either about a capital scene
but the anthropo not seen the human
knowledge that is getting extincted and
we are not aware also how much they have
been communicated
with with others and then i think so
everybody was aware that
the last year we have heard the words i
cannot breathe from george floyd
does this means it seems we have a
trouble not only to communicate
with animals but also we have a
fundamental problem to communicate among
ourselves i mean this a little bit and
maybe we can put again the images
if we want to go through when we invited
evan simply
to play the clarinet i don't know if we
can do that image for me something which
was
astonishing besides being an amazing
composer he will play if we can play
that image he will be great he's having
trying to play the clarinet uh he's
all the time playing playing this tiger
do not move at all
and he keep playing for almost half an
hour and the spider do not react at all
he seems the vibration that the clarinet
and the sound that
heaven was playing the spider didn't
bother and then we got
almost exhausted after half an hour of
playing and then everything
put the images down below it's okay
there because
these are many musicians we have invited
to interact with webs and spider and see
to jam together and in that moment evan
put the clarinet on the table
and that vibration is what the spider
really love it and start to pick up
has been somehow having completely
forgot about how to play the instrument
but about rubbing it on the tables and
start to forget all the knowledge
to try to then to communicate with the
vibration mode that is whether maybe was
much more attuned
and maybe i leave it evan to you to talk
a little bit about this
uh i don't think i can do better than
that tomas but i i will say that i
i i remember that moment very well and i
i
it's actually easy to forget when you
don't have that much knowledge
so um that was not a problem but i do
remember the process of letting go of
will was really more what it had to do
with that
i was trying to figure out what the
spider
might want to hear or might want to say
or how we could make a sound that would
sound good together and then at a
certain point i just let go of that
desire
and that's at least for me was the
subjective experience
yesterday um one of the questions that
we didn't get to answer was
is it a matter of forgetting your human
form of thinking
uh and you pointed out that there's not
just one human form of thinking
um but i think it's you know it's not
possible to
know whether you're forgetting how to be
a human but i think it's just a matter
of being open to what you're receiving
and not trying so hard to interpret it
but just reacting and being with it
yeah and i think so something a little
bit to to give
resonance to maybe even what you are
talking i will read a little bit
something that hit on japan kevin london
have been thought spiders appear to
offload
the cognitive task to their webs making
one of the number of species with a mind
that is not fully confined within the
head in truth
these webbed bodies is an extension of
the spider
own diffusing its sense and thoughts
beyond the shells
or its carpets through
through each silk threat her legs
stretch themself across across
the ether and so become sensor membranes
of the world
so two her minds reach across their
tension surface
feeling to the pulses that tremble in it
the vibration
through which the spider build the
picture of the world beyond i mean it's
this idea really like because when
sometimes science and i go to all
science museum around the world they
always showed a collection of spiders
but not as spider webs it means again
about this idea of coupling decoupling
the umvelt or what jacqueline voxel
always tried to understand what is the
milieu and how much
our extended body somehow it
interrelated
with maybe the webs that we are trying
to build together with arachnophilia
yeah it's wonderful maybe uh one other
thing that we we didn't get to talk
about yet i mentioned at the beginning
is that
we we have played pay attention to the
vibrations of these uh spider webs in
different circumstances and one of the
um enabled projects that have come out
of this collaboration really across the
three or three teams i would say
was a project that evan and christine i
think christine actually joined us as
well
uh maybe ivan christine you can share a
little bit about your um
acrophilia implementation in the
arachnodrone which was using the virtual
reality environment of the scanned web
as a musical instrument by playing that
on stage and i have a couple of
photos this is one here and i can cycle
through other ones while you speak so
maybe i'll hand it over to
christina nevan to discuss that a little
bit more
i'm sorry to interrupt but i think we
only have one minute left
um but if it's possible to get a blast
of
sound and image that would be fantastic
i'm gonna go yeah if you can start
talking and i'll i'll put up the video
and then we can play that towards the
end
okay um well first uh christine was able
to join i'm mindful of the time and as a
result i just put the web
a web link in the chat uh which i don't
know if the viewers can watch but if you
go to arachnodrone.com
there are various there's information
about this installation as well as
video and audio clips here's a little
bit now
um so what you're seeing obviously was
inspired in many levels of
first of all by this incredible
certafora spider that isabelle
uh not isabel and marcus's studio um
helped with the scanning and then built
a virtual model of
and it was put into unity game software
to create this virtual harp
13 000 string harp
and the look of it obviously as
mentioned is inspired by tomas and in
fact this was at a presentation at
tomas's
exhibition of the palais but also was
designed by christine southworth
who also performed it she's here now if
she wants to say a little bit about the
look for as much time as we have
so yes the look you see the web moving
which is actually the scan
of the web turned into basically
a game and then on top of that
we overlaid images of spider webs from
around um around massachusetts and
actually around england because we were
there for a residency
um so there's different there's
like tomasz's work there's layers of
different spider webs
creating um what you see
um and then the audio which we can't
hear
is but you can hear it if you go to the
website um is the sound
of that web as we're playing it as we're
going through it
and with us improvising so again it was
improvising
with the web but the web was an
instrument on its own
i'm really sorry i think we're going to
have to leave it there but please
everyone
the um the address is already
in in the um chat and uh
please check it out it sounds truly
amazing project
thank you so much thank you everyone
thank you um and please stay on yeah for
the chat
at the end and now we're over to lars
chitka
from queen mary university of london um
do beautiful all right sunflowers
thank you i'll just share my screen
so
um let's see
can you see my presentation now
great thank you all right so my name's
lars chitka i'm a b
psychologist in my day job i study the
sensory systems
the cognition intelligence and the
emotions of bees
and this is a slightly unusual project
for me i collaborated with an
installation artist julian walker
who was at the time interested in
evaluating audience responses
to paintings in museums and over a few
drinks
we came together to explore how bees
might respond
to historic paintings
this was presented at a conference on
the physics of color and we decided to
stir the pot a little bit with this uh
slightly unusual project
now interspecies communication
is everywhere in biology we the human
species haven't
invented such communication it even
exists across plants and animals so
flowers of course
are communications signals that
have an information content they signal
to pollinators
the quantity and quality of rewards that
the pollinators in turn
learn to associate with these signals
but the the sensory modalities by which
these information contents are conveyed
are wholly different from um the human
realm
so as the the um poet christina rossetti
pointed out and other eyes than ours
were made to look on flowers insect eyes
are strange
as you can see you can't easily relate
to them in the way that you can extract
perhaps emotional responses from looking
into vertebrate eyes is strange but
certainly beautiful
and one of the many strangeness strange
aspects of it is that they
extract wholly different sensory
contents
from the environment we humans in terms
of color
have blue green and red receptors if you
superimpose
their sensitivity on the visual on the
spectrum
you can see their sensitivity curves
here with maxima in the blue green and
red
bees and all other insects in fact many
other animals
have an ultraviolet receptor they're
sensitive in a range of electromagnetic
radiation where we have no sensitivity
whatsoever
however their long wave receptor is a
green receptor which doesn't extend
quite as far into the red as ours does
there's a little bbc clip about our work
on uv
reflectance so if i could ask the
masterminds of the video presentation
the nectar and the pollen in these
flowers is in the center
these flowers present a kind of bullseye
pattern where the periphery is a
brightly
shining uv signal that can be seen from
a distance
whereas the center of the flower absorbs
the ultraviolet and this pattern guides
the bead to the center
so she can locate the nectar and the
pollen then
[Music]
it's just amazing what the ultraviolet
camera reveals
it shows the secret signals sent by
flowers
which guide the bees to the exact place
where the nectar is hidden
all right thank you let's switch back to
the the main screen
so a little reminder also that there are
multiple other
sensory differences between insects b
specifically
and ours so in addition to seeing
ultraviolet bees can also see
polarized light they have a sensitivity
to the earth's magnetic field that can
respond to electrical signals
from flowers and they can sense petal
microstructure
so the world we see is not the objective
of the real world
different animals perceive very
different aspects of their environment
typically through filters that they have
acquired throughout evolution
in line with their lifestyle so no
animal sees a complete
or somehow real picture of the
physical world around them
so the project with julian walker
involved
presenting bees that had never seen a
flower before
um on their maiden flights basically
with
various paintings one of them was
vincent van gogh's sunflowers
there was patrick caulfield's pottery uh
paul gorgon's
a vows of flowers and foreign
still life with a beer mug
sunflowers by the way don't actually
have a strong or not a pronounced
pattern in the ultraviolet
a relatively subtle
gradient of uv reflectance in this right
picture you can see here taken through
the uv filter so bees
responded to these paintings with
some enthusiasm you can see two
individuals here having landed in the
center of one of
the sunflowers here is something in the
still life with beer mug that
attracted the interest of b red 23
um and so on there's a little video clip
again if you could play that back of
bees actually responding live
to these flowers
so you can see they're landing in the
centers of the flowers typically
again these are entirely flower naive
beans i've never seen
flowers before they've been exposed to
these paintings
[Music]
all right that's enough i think thank
you
so in terms of quantities of responses
in terms of approach flights that each
of the paintings
attracted van gogh's was clearly the
most
popular that was also the case in terms
of landings on the flowers which were
far
fewer these are the little white bars
here
the second highest popularity of
actual landings was gorgonz painting
um so this is this is an overview of
these responses but clearly van gogh's
sunflower is where the most um
attractive by these now we run this
project by our audience
clearly to provoke thinking about
differences in
perception and aesthetics and so on and
so we wanted some responses from
our audience about initial conference
many expressed amusement and thought
well this is just uh
surreal and absurd why are you doing
this um
some of the artists at the conference
actually felt that the flowers are not
intended for bees when gulf sunflowers
are clearly for human audiences that
felt that bees were
somehow invading the paintings
someone said that van gogh must have
unwittingly captured the essence of a
flower
in terms of what matters to bees
and we just threw several questions
back at our audience and i will leave
you with these questions so
one is why is it obvious that flowers
rendered by painters should be different
from those of from those which have
evolved to attract bees
what is always tell us about the biology
of senses and of aesthetic preferences
in what sense do humans have a kind of
ownership
about flowers created by not by by
artificial selection
on by way of horticulture
or creation through artists why is it
inappropriate that these should be
interacting interacted with by
pollinators
and what evolutionary reason might there
be for
humans widespread attraction to flowers
so if you enjoy this kind of
interface between the sciences and the
arts there's a lot of poetry in the
weird
world of bees and their interactions
with flowers so i actually have a
concept album out and bandcamp entitled
strange flowers
um so have fun with that thank you very
much
thank you thank you so much um lars that
is
uh really fascinating and i gather you
also have a track called i stung gwyneth
paltrow is that correct
that is correct yes so we have to hear
that too
um okay well next up uh
is from claire brooks google arts and
culture um and christina tarkini
and i think we have a video now on the
heartbeat of the earth
hi everyone and thank you so much for
the invitation
to this very important discussion and
conversation
i'm claire brooks and i'm joined by
christina tarquini
a digital artist from italy who i've
collaborated with many times in the past
and uh we will be taking a deep dive
into
the mediterranean sea with her a bit
later
but first i wanted to introduce you to
google answer culture experiments
as a google arts and culture lab and we
collaborate with experts creatives
curators
artists scientists and educators to help
craft
new bridges between technology and
culture
and heartbeat of the earth is a program
that i lead at google arts and culture
lab
in which we're collaborating across
disciplines with artists creative coders
designers and scientists
and we're focusing on one of today's
most pressing issues
which is climate change
why art art has always been a medium to
convey complex subjects and address
challenges that we face artists are
often
also thinking 10 years ahead art is
about connecting with people's emotions
it's personal and at the same time it's
universal
i believe that commissioning and
collaborating with an artist is based on
trust and truth especially when focusing
on topics that have an impact
on society and the world at large
when topics are too remote too explosive
and too complicated for us to comprehend
then i believe that this is when it's
our responsibility to reach out to
artists
who will take this challenge to connect
with people's emotions
for many of us the term climate data
conjures up images of complicated graphs
and charts
but artists are explaining it through
new lens as you see here
these are some of the artworks or like
actually all of the artworks that are
based
that are part of heartbeat of the earth
the artists that you see here are all
those who also collaborated on an
artwork
for the program and more and more
artists are in fact taking steps and
doing research in scientific fields and
so
opening up the dialogue for an
interesting bridge between science and
art
by striving to move away from our
anthropocentric views
artists can also create the bridge
between our understanding of the world
and other other species understanding
the animals plants or any element that
surrounds us visible or not
and we believe that technology can play
a part in this and be a powerful vehicle
to engage audiences and help the tan the
intangible become
tangible through heartbeat of the earth
which is an artist's residency at google
as a culture lab that we launched with
the unf triple z
the climate change the artist
collaborations translate
complex climate science and allow us to
experience hard data
through the senses by emerging art and
technology
we can create a new way of understanding
science
and we collaborated with the artists to
turn their proposals into artworks
now we'll take a deep dive into one
particular experimental artwork
and fruitful collaboration which is
medusae by christina tarquini
we'll look at how a collaboration
between artists technology and
scientists can open up the interspecies
dialogue and allow us to see what
jellyfish can teach us about climate
change
i'll hand over to christina to briefly
introduce the artwork
thank you claire and thank you very much
for having us yes so my name is
christina tarquini and together
we clear in google arts and culture and
we created
meduse which is an interactive web
data visualization that focuses on
jellyfish species
and in particular jellyfish blooms in
the mediterranean seas
to understand the changing climate the
mediterranean is an era that's very dear
to me but also
um is considered the cradle of western
civilization
and but unfortunately so even though
it's so important unfortunately it's
it's warming
one of the fastest spaces in the world
it is um so you're probably asking
yourselves why focus on jellyfish um
actually one of the key points that drew
me to your proposal christina was this
new way of seeing or understanding
this creature that most people would
probably call pest or a nuisance to most
swimmers
you know going on holiday in the summer
um but it's actually
a marvel full of clues to you yeah
definitely for me jellyfish are amazing
like
it it's surprising that uh for me
surprising at least that people
look at jellyfish as you are saying the
pets the pests
the weeds of the ocean just an
aggressive invasive species
uh that just ruins your day at the end
of the day and if we
look at them as being really the lowest
class in the animal kingdom but of
course this is just a truly
anthropocentric view and if you ask me
also a very egoistic one
and not only towards jellyfish but also
how we perceive animal in general um but
to me jellyfish are really special
because they have been on this planet
for more than 670 million years so
they're much older
than dinosaurs and they've been here for
the oldest living creature that has been
on this planet and during this amount of
time
they've adapted um to live in such
special conditions so for example they
become transparent which
in the ocean is extremely important
because it means that they can hide in
plain sight
of or for example they learned how to
live forever there's some jellyfish that
if
left undisturbed they never dies um
and so they have this special skills
that for me that makes them
just marvelous and of course it's not
actually just to me
they've also influenced and inspired
many fields like
robotics genetics and chemistry for
example
definitely and there's one really fun
fact that you also taught me
um during the project yeah definitely
there is a
thanks to the bioluminescence of
jellyfish a scientist won a nobel prize
so it's
as if a jellyfish itself won a nobel
prize
that's brilliant um also during the
collaboration process we were constantly
meeting and feeding back to each other
on the different ways of approaching the
topic
and we decided upon focusing on the
climate issues in relation to the
jellyfish instead of
doing a deep dive in the specific
species themselves
um because this actually enabled a more
like a broader and more open
uh educational element to the artwork so
that we could view these creatures as
less of a foe
and more of a hero of the story yeah
definitely climate change affects
jellyfish differently than other
fish species they're the marine species
in fact for example acidifying waters
that
harm their jelly instead they harm all
the fish
rising temperatures are not yet an arm
to them
the lack of oxygen doesn't find itself
as a problem
jellyfish can live in waters where
there's little no oxygen at all
and the fact that we've basically
overfished all their predators
just allow them to thrive in our seas so
is
as as you claire we're saying definitely
they aren't the antagonists of the story
we are
just doing the work for them and over
the years
as i grew up in italy i've definitely
seen their number increasing
um and that and the more i've done my
research the more i've seen that
they actually serve a clue to the
changing climate today we talk
uh very much about data visualization so
making numbers
visuals and pretty and understandable by
everybody
but i think jellyfish blooms are a
natural data visualization
it's almost as if nature is doing this
to give us a sign
a clue um and uh yes so
then during in the experience we did we
it into climate
chapters um so that user can discover
jellyfish
species but also understand what's
happening to the mediterranean sea
and then also interestingly the research
i've made prior to the collaboration uh
had drawn me to some really interesting
studies that transformed jellyfish into
part of the solution instead of being
the problem
um because the important message that we
wanted to present was a conclusion that
was more hopeful than
than doomfall and so ending with a
positive note on the species was kind of
paramount to our call to action
perhaps christina you could very quickly
tell us more about what these
creative solutions are yeah definitely i
mean in italy there is
well this is something that i'm really
proud of there's a lot of critics
solution using jellyfish
for example there is a lot of scientists
that are now turning themselves into
chefs
uh because they are trying to tackle the
problem
of having so many jellyfish in the sea
and less and less
food that can be put for on the table
and so they're looking at transforming
jellyfish in really
delicious food or there is this other
very interesting project there is
looking at using jellyfish mucus to
gather
micro plastic from the sea as we all
know microplastic and plastic is an
environmental crisis that is
uh as big if not bigger climate change
um and so this is all very very
interesting and yes as you were saying
claire we wanted to keep it open
uh to creative solutions definitely and
i also wanted to bring a very important
point to the fore um of the the
experience was the
importance of the scientific
corroboration in all of these artworks
and
christina collaborated very closely with
baby
from the laboratory
on all the topics in research mentioned
and you can also see the data sources
used here on this slide
thank you so much christina for allowing
us to see jellyfish in a positive light
and for taking us in this beautiful deep
dive into the mediterranean sea
i'm available for live questions after
this talk so see you all soon
thank you hi there well that was
fantastic
um i'm very lucky right now i'm by the
mediterranean sea and one of the
favorite things
we love to do is go and look at the
bioluminescence at nighttime
but anyway we've got unfortunately
we don't have claire and christina with
us but um we will try and
pass on any questions to them for anyone
who has some specific questions
for their work um the i have one here
for lars could you test how the bees
might respond to these same paintings
in gray values to see if they also
responded to just the form
they will do yes
but the it depends on which part of the
response you're evaluating
so attraction from a distance and
detection of
flowers is done with just a single color
receptor type the green receptor
and that's therefore color a color blind
channel
once they're closer to the flowers and
identifying
recognizing them from memory they use
the entire color spectrum
and actually use predominantly color
over intensity
fantastic um and now to the spider team
um is there a specific instruments
vibration
that the spiders seem to prefer or react
more to in your
studio or studies sorry
tomas has uh had so many musicians
playing with his spiders that he might
be able to answer that
more broadly uh in my own experience i
didn't think it was so much about
vibration or i mean i was playing one
instrument which is bass clarinet
but it was more about getting i
i wasn't so much thinking about
frequency vibration
bass clarinet has a particular uh sound
envelope that's pretty distinctive it
basically replicates a square wave
so that's cool but uh i it was more had
to do with
the way i was playing i was thinking
about about
my own vibration i don't mean that in a
new age sense but just literally
my own motion and how i what i know
about the spider what i was hearing from
the spider
but i only did it that one time so tomas
do you have more to say is he still with
us
i just wanted to note so when we were
at the palais tokyo we had a spider in
the room
um so we were playing and we had
surround sound we had
um i think it was four
speakers and a subwoofer they may we may
have had
additional subwoofers so when we
played low that spider
actually felt it in her whip um and she
was just on the other side of the room
so
i think the low vibrations um
i mean i think it was actually the the
vibrations rather than the sound
i mean sound is vibration but it was the
vibrations that she was reacting to
and she could actually feel what we were
making
but let me just say two quick things
about that first of all um
you know as humans we give ourselves the
right to react to music
without moving we can move or we don't
have to move so
all we can know is whether the spite
we're seeing the spider
or measuring the spider reacting doesn't
mean she's not thinking about it
but also i will say that uh tomas
himself did film
the spider that was in the room with us
while we were playing
so we could put that question to him
later yeah
and can spiders moonwook
sorry they got yeah
they they have eight legs
yeah you can do lots more with it yeah
um
so are there plans to further spider
research in a more
natural controlled environment using
plants native to the spider's habitat
um hello peter hi claire
hey yes no absolutely
hey one thing peter is always like
what what we discussed a little bit
yesterday you know
you know it's very natural for a spider
also to
weave a web in the corner of a house and
this mean
you know they have these animals which
are phenotropic this means they don't
have this kind of western division
of uh you know that the corner of a
house which is 90 degree
is less natural than the branch of a
tree
they don't have that extension you know
what i mean is i think so you know to
certain extent we have to maybe revision
this idea where nature start and end to
certain extent but yes of course
we observe in you know usually every
time we go to a museum
we watch all where spiders live in the
museum right and this means you can find
them
everywhere so i love the idea that you
talked about
the web becoming an extension of the
body
and i was just wondering yeah it was a
new type of architecture where we could
connect our houses in the same way to uh
to our senses um anyway that's
we actually started studying webs out in
nature and i i put a little link in me
in the chat as well
um the the challenges when you have
natural webs
from a science perspective it's very
difficult to understand exactly the
parameters
um and measure the web and so we
actually um in this collaboration with
tomas we moved
webs from nature in situ studying there
into the lab which allowed us to do a
lot of things like the scanning and the
virtual reality
and ultimately music and all these
things in a much more controlled way
but but i do think it's very interesting
if you go out to nature and uh
and study webs you know we in this paper
that i post that we
actually discovered that the the
architecture and the material
and the weights built is very closely
linked very different from current
architecture where
as an architecture engineer you take a
material off the shelf basically and you
build around that material
the spider is able to control the
material
yeah no i i could not i don't know peter
it was
here my answer before uh yeah
we it was a little broken up but uh but
i think uh we got it thank you
okay good great um there's a question
from
vint saying octopuses have huge
neural structure in their arms to manage
them independently
what do we know about spider
neurostructure
yes i don't know marcus if you want to
answer
no please go ahead no no but yes i think
so it's very
throwful the the relationship uh
in relationship of this what we said
before of offloading
the capacity of the of the thinking
through the web
for example when you have a spider which
is not able to weave a web
she will not eat at all and this image
she don't
come complete and is able to weave kind
of the mouse
so where she will be able to sense then
what she will be eating she will not eat
and she should not weave the web doesn't
mean somehow she really kind of
build this kind of embody or extend the
cognition through the web
and it's part of the brain and also for
example the tension that they put in the
lines
it depends how much hungry is the spider
doesn't mean if there is a lot of
tension in the web she will tension it a
lot
even a small praise will be able to be
sensed if
and she when she's already fed and is
not so hungry the tension of the threats
are much more loose this is small praise
will not be able
to be sensed by the spider it's been
it's really this idea of thinking that
the brain is not confined
to the you know the the way of thinking
is not confined to the brain
yeah they feel their weave all the time
and adding to this is an interesting
thing that actually the silk that's used
to make the web
itself has some built-in responsiveness
so for example if you take spider silk
and you expose it to moisture
um the silks will actually the set will
actually compress and
create tension by itself and so there's
sort of an additional component of not
only the web is a living material
but also the material itself has
built-in mechanisms to respond to the
environment such as moisture and
basically
stiffen up and create a different
attention so it's an amazing ecosystem i
think from
from many perspectives yeah i i was
always
fascinated by the well-known photos
of the webs that were constructed
um on different drugs and
how they how different they were do you
think that was in some ways a
representation is is the web in some way
um mapping brain activity
uh in that way yeah peter there is a
beautiful sample of a wasp it's called
the zombie spiral
which hijacked the brain of the spider
and then the spider started to
to build a web which is not anymore her
archetypical type of web but
build a web to host the babies of the
wasps which were
bought in the in the body of the spider
this mean is really this kind of
hijacking the brain by the other animal
and then the spiders start to build a
completely different
web that it's used to to do this mean
this idea also when we were talking
about
how spiders are affected by different
types and
and i will mention how much pollution is
affected
on the web also this is why i have been
displaced from
because they they are proteins as marco
said they eat the web when they eat all
the black carbon and the
soothing the pollution which is in there
with the puzzle on the web then they die
also and they're really affected by
pollution
wow um i think
yeah we're coming to a close to the
break but is there anything else
um everyone would like to add um last
year
about where you think things might be in
ten years or where you'd like them to be
well i think as we're learning more
about the
psychology of even very small brained
animals
we're increasingly starting to think
about the ethics
the ethical implications that come with
that there are currently no
legal restrictions for example on
invasive experimentation with insects
um so you can experimental scientists
can drill
electrodes of any number into their
brains without any kind of anesthetic
and so on and of course
well you might be aware of the plight of
many insects including bees in nature
and people are aware that we need to
conserve bees because we need them to
pollinate our crops and so on but i
think
with the increasing insights into their
psychology there are also
ethical concerns with killing insects on
a large scale
and or subjecting them to laboratory
treatments in the manner that is
currently the case so
i'd like that to change okay fantastic
um i think we're pretty much uh out of
time
and ready for the break but it's been a
really amazing session and
i think there's plenty for all of us to
think about and i hope everyone will go
and check these projects
on their own websites and i'm sure we'll
have the links
uh in interspecies io dot io
um just wanted to thank all of you yeah
for
giving up your time and uh inspiring us
so uh amazing session
thank you so much
yeah we've got a 15 minute break i
[Music]
believe